This is a great privilege and a great honor for me
because The Moth really exists, because of
this man.
Because when I
started, you know, years ago I was in Georgia and I
was sitting on a porch with my friends and blah, blah, blah, and we had the
moths zipping around and I thought,  "OK. We're going to
have a
Moth Group
here." Somehow I began to think I can bring this to New York.
But I started to get afraid that I might not be able
to actually present it in New York because in New York people get a
little antsy about stories. And then
I saw this movie, My Dinner With Andre, which is
just -- is it two hours long?  It's just, I don't know how long it is, but it's just a movie
with nothing but this man telling stories. And it is a riveting,
fascinating movie. And that was the inspiration we realized we can do this.
So I would like to introduce to you the star of that movie and many other
movies, and a brilliant director, Andre Gregory.
(applause)
Thank you. Thank
you for that lovely introduction. Does this go down a bit?  Or should it?  Can you see my face?  My eyes?  Is that alright?
There
Well great. Thank you, thank you very much.
I thought tonight,
I would tell you a story about the first time that I fell deeply,
deeply in love because everybody here can identify with falling in love.  If
my wife Cindy will forgive me because actually every day with her is like the first
time.
That's the miracle of it.  The very first time, when I was in
college, I fell in love with a woman who looked
very much like ?Katie? actually.  And I'm not just saying that  -- I'm really not just saying that
so that you won't play the violin.  But
she was, she
was she was beautiful and tall she was a brunette she was just a little bit different and, uh,
But I think before telling you the story -- her name was Ina -- I think before telling you the story,
I need to tell you so you'll understand the story, just a little bit about my childhood. Now I may
have asked this question before, but how many of you have seen "The
Shining?" Right. Well that was a documentary about my
childhood. I'm not kidding. This is true. This is true.
I was never touched, kissed, or hugged. Ever. I kid you not.
I was brought up by nannies, in fact the first nanny I had was a
German who hated little babies who cried. So she
put Seconal in my milk.  And
my mother and my grandmother knew very little
about children. But after I'd been sleeping for twenty six hours they figured
that something must be wrong with me. So they took me to the American Hospital in Paris and they pumped my stomach.
And they like to laugh a lot about
the fact that for about a year afterwards I would kind of, you know, do a
few steps and then I would just kind of fall down to go to sleep.  And I would
always think of my parents, God bless them, sort of as Macbeth and Lady Macbeth.
But you know we've all had difficult parents. And the nice thing really,
but the nice thing about growing older is you learn to forgive
and to realize that they were just human beings like us and they made their mistakes.
But it's important for this story that you know that I was never touched,
hugged or kissed,
right? So I fell in love with Ina.  She was at Radcliffe and I was at
Harvard and it just never occurred to me that a beautiful,
really intelligent, wonderful woman could love me, you know.  So we went
out to breakfast and lunch and dinner and we went to courses together and we'd go out and
we'd talk about Schopenhauer
and Kierkegaard, you know. But I would have never thought of touching
her and because you know why would she ever love this sort of strange
monster that was
me?  And this went on for months. I think she thought I was gay.
And one . . .  I was just madly in love with her, but I would have just never ever
thought of touching her.
And one night when we'd been going out for two months but
there was never anything romantic about it, we went out to this very beautiful graveyard
in Marblehead, Massachusetts.  The graveyard was kind of appropriate because her father was the
largest casket manufacturer in America. That's true, he was --
(Bachmann) Caskets.  And it was a
beautiful moonlit night and I guess she got so frustrated that she
suddenly just grabbed me and quite passionately kissed
me.  And I fainted.
This is true. My knees gave way and
I fainted.
And we went out for a couple of
months
afterwards. It got a little romantic and then, it's a
sad story because I went to pick her up one night at
her dorm and she'd completely disappeared. She never got the nerve to tell me that she was
engaged to a Marine captain in
Korea. And she went home to tell her parents that she wanted to marry me
and get out of this wedding and her father said You better talk to your mother and her mother
said you know we've got the gifts we've got the tent we've got the orchestra -- all girls
go through this. Everyone's nervous before a wedding. So she married somebody else.
Now. And I was deeply, deeply depressed. Now,
the amazing thing about the first time of anything,
but especially when you fall in love, is
that there never is anything quite like it because literally twenty
five years later,
I was at Elaine's for a New Year's Eve party.  And I'd been
married for
I think twenty or twenty five years. And suddenly, in walked Ina. I
know. And my heart started to pound, you know.  And,
and my mouth went dry and I couldn't think of anything to say.
And we sat opposite each other, you know, at this big table with all these people.
And there was music and all night, I kept thinking, "Oh, if only we
could have one dance."  You know, I hadn't seen her in twenty five years.
And just as the evening was over she came over and she said to me would you like to
dance. And we started to dance. And we started to dance cheek to
cheek and at the very end of the dance just very very delicately, she kissed
me on the lips, and I
fainted.  This
is true. This is this is really true.  The power
of love is an amazing thing.
But there's, I think that
there's a lesson to the first time. Because we've all of
us experienced an extraordinary first time
in something or in many things. Our first creative success.
The first time that we've fallen in love.  The first time we were
naked in front of a human
being.  The first
time is an amazing
thing. And it never happens
again. When it's happened that first
time, it's never quite the same thing again. But the lesson,
the lesson which is
a, I think, a deep spiritual lesson, is
in our lives to try to
make every single thing we
do, the first time. Every encounter we
have, the first time. Every meeting we
have, the first time. Every time we see a stop
light turn green or turn
red, to look at that light with the eyes of a
child and the eyes of wonder.
And in that
way, from moment to moment and from day to day,
we can all be in a
state of ecstasy, fear,
wonder and amazement. And
that is what it is to be
truly alive. Thank you.
(applause)
a
looney Thank
you.